l'ambiance était bouillante ce week-end
au gymnase Pierre Bérégovoy de
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine l'équipe élite
du Conflans Andrésy jouit volley-ball
accueillait un final Faure une finale à
4 en français en Coupe de France
fédérale un rendez-vous qui a attiré des
centaines de spectateurs l'ambiance
était superbe donc effectivement je
pense que ça a galvanisé les joueurs à
partir de là
l'adversaire était de qualité mais
effectivement ça a sans doute fait la
différence ouais il y avait une très
très bonne confiance dans les tribunes
très bon enfant voilà on encouragé notre
équipe évidemment mais l'autre équipe a
bien joué également
un bon match comme ça à domicile après
un match d'une rare intensité l'équipe
coacher par Philippe montaudoin a
remporté la demi-finale le samedi les
joueurs n'ont rien lâché jusqu'au bout
super content et en plus après un tel
match une telle intensité on va chercher
le tie-break à deux points d'écart ça a
été coupé pendant enfin voilà un super
spectacle qui a eu du monde j'aurais été
le plus malheureux des hommes si on
avait paumé mais en plus on a gagné avec
une belle ambiance des partenaires des
élus qui était là c'est voilà c'est
c'est chouette une ambiance de fou à
Conflans c'est vraiment bien et ça ça
nous porte quand même pour pouvoir aller
chercher des victoires comme celle-là ou
c'est très dur de jouer contre une belle
équipe d'allure le lendemain dimanche 16
avril le club de volley-ball Conflans
Andrésy jouit à une nouvelle fois
brillée mené 2-0 par Caudry l'équipe a
réalisé une remontada en s'imposant 3,2
objectif accompli il remporte la Coupe
de France fédérale